what up space fam goes in here from
anime outpour and I'm back at it again
to discuss some mhm a fact it's finally
time to cover our epic class 1a teacher
shota
Aizawa aka eraser head if you do enjoy
seeing mhm a FAQ videos on this channel
and want to keep them coming the best
thing to do is Detroit smash that like
button until it's blue and share this
video with fellow friends who recognize
the greatness of my ear academia if this
video hits 4000 likes that's right 4,000
I'll get CERN on the next installment
ASAP if you haven't be sure subscribe
this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future my hero academia videos as
always let me know who you want to see
covered next in the comments of this
video this is already the eleventh video
in the MHA facts series so feel free to
check out the playlist link in the
description in order to find out which
characters I've covered already now
without further ado let's jump into it
for fact number one let's look at shota
aizawa's name because as we know what of
course she's a wordsmith and his naming
is topped here in every case that I can
think of Honaker she makes sure that his
characters have names that reflect their
personality quirk and/or other things
about them in aizawa's case his name
contains a Japanese character for erase
which points to his ability to erase
other people's quirks and he also
possesses the character for counselor
and as a teacher he definitely gives
advice to his students and serves as an
important representative of UA his
friend present Mike was the one who gave
him his hero name Eraserhead back in the
day it's perfect in a way because his
ability to erase quirks does come from
his head specifically from his eyes if
you've tried googling Eraserhead like me
you'll also realize that Aizawa shares
the name of an experimental film that I
very much don't recommend watching if
you're easily freaked out knowing what
Akashi and how he's a fan of so many
American works of art I bet that this
movie's title did in fact inspire him to
make aizawa's hero named Eraserhead
for fact number 2 let's look at aizawa's
popularity in japan there have been 5
popularity polls thus far in the first
poll Aizawa got in 9th place between Eva
the Hedgehog and Deng Keita Pikachu the
more flashy all might god 5th place
making AI solid the second top ranked
teacher in the first poll however for
the second poll the laid-back
she like Aizawa stole people's hearts
and came in fourth place right between
Todoroki and Kirishima all my team in
sixth place in the second poll so Aizawa
was the top ranking teacher in this one
despite his laid-back on flashy ways in
the third poll he moved out to sixth
place still maintaining his lead above
the seventh place all might in the
fourth poll he dropped and actually fell
below quite a few pro hero's an 11th
place he ranked below all might endeavor
best genus and hawks who got as high as
fourth place however in the most recent
poll Iowa climbed back up to sixth place
placing between shigaraki and or Chaco
and in this poll he reclaimed his title
of most popular teacher and pro hero
I love seeing Aizawa being so popular
because he's clearly the guy who
wouldn't care about popularity contests
at all and yet he's often more popular
than all might endeavor two heroes who
are clearly way flashier than the all
black wearing withdrawn Eraserhead for
fact number three let's see how Iowa
fared in the US compared to Japan is he
as popular or more popular here in the
West well in the first poll he was
definitely less popular compared to 9th
place in the first Japanese poll he got
20th place in the first US poll ranking
even lower than purple balls Minetta
however he moved his way up the polls
and by the 4th and 5th polls he was the
top ranking teacher and pro hero in the
u.s. in the fourth poll he got 6th place
behind Momo and in front of all mine and
in the 5th poll which was shared on
December 15 2019 he stayed in 6th place
he was still behind Momo but this time
Hawkes was trailing him so yeah whether
in Japan or the u.s. at first I saw was
stood out less than heroes like all
might but with time everyone comes to
love this guy who cares so little about
what other people think that he's
willing to sleep on the school's floor
without a second thought I said it
before I'll say it again my goal is to
develop aizawa's level of not caring for
fact number 4 let's explore how funny
coffee came up with the idea for the
character of Aizawa but of course she
writes at Aizawa is a man who lives by
the motto of logic ality in other words
his decisions are based on logic to the
extreme rather than on emotions
what of course she explains that it was
from this concept of a character who
thought everything through to their
logical conclusion
that aizawa's design emerged in Iowa's
case it leads him not to fuss over his
appearance in the eyes of the public at
large thus he's much more similar to a
character like Shikamaru from Naruto
then he is to a character like calm
uniform good and logon who talks about
kicking reason to the curb and doing the
impossible there's something in
characters like Shikamaru and Aizawa
that I love they don't try to stand out
they act like everything is a drag but
they are effective AF when the chips are
down this explanation by honey Cauchy
explains why eraser head just has a
black uniform rather than a flashy one
hey he's less likely to attract the
villains of tension and be a flashy
outfit wouldn't help him fight better so
there's no logical reason to complicate
things of course there is something to
be said for the power of emotions and
the way all might inspires people so I
think that these two balance out each
other in a great way for fact number
five let's look at some personal info
about Aizawa for starters he likes cats
more than anything it makes sense that
he's a cat person since cats can be
understated and standoffish like Aizawa
while dogs on the other hand can be very
loud in your face and drooling all over
you I'm still a dog person myself but
even I can't help but appreciate how
much
Aizawa likes cats when he was younger
people told him as a hero he should
smile more you know like all mine I saw
it naturally where's all his stress and
doubts on his face not making citizens
feel super safe but when he Scrolls
through pictures of cats on his phone he
can't help but light up with a smile
which is all the more priceless because
he smiles so rarely
besides the cats I'll mention that
according to what across the eyes all's
room has nothing in it
aka it's quite empty this makes perfect
sense with his personality if there
isn't a logical conclusion to having
something he won't have it so he's like
an extreme minimalist who'd probably
just have a bed for sleeping and maybe a
table and chair for working in his room
and nothing more you won't see posters
of all might all over his room
I like that about Aizawa too because I'm
also into the idea of minimalism in
Aizawa is a great role model for people
who want to trim out the excess and live
a more bare-bones Spartan sort of life
as always definitely a guy who won't let
the things he owns end up owning him and
with that Fight Club reference out of
the way let's move on to fact number 6
for this fact let's break that all over
sir heads pro-hero equipment and as we
know it is all there because it serves a
specific function as we all probably
know by now
Aizawa squirt lets him erase people's
quirks when he looks at that if he
blinks the spell will be broken and the
quirk in question will no longer be
erased so he has to keep his eyes open a
long time in some cases try yourself and
you'll see how hard it is
it's no wonder aizawa's eyes are always
bloodshot in order to help him keep his
eyes open for longer Aizawa carries
around eyedrops as part of his pro hero
equipment which is kind of funny when
you imagine a hero like Batman taking a
break from a fight to put in eyedrops
but it does make sense for Aizawa
obviously as quirk is not like all mites
for Bach who goes and by this I mean
aizawa's quirk doesn't increase his
physical combat skills he can't shoot
fire or punch like Superman so he
actually had to become the strong
fighter and find a way to be effective
in battle without the help of a no peek
work in order to assist him he uses the
capturing weapon that usually hangs
around his neck this weapon is a cloth
made from steel wire alloy woven with
carbon nanofibers so it's strong AF and
can hold down most people Iowa keeps a
large knife on him so that he can cut
this cloth if it gets caught on
something thus making sure he doesn't
get trapped by his own weapon we've also
seen him used caltrops a key spiked
metal devices that you throw on the
ground they can pop car tires and
obviously do some serious damage to
humans as well if you trap someone and
suspends them in the air using his
capturing weapon he can drop these
caltrops on the ground below them in
order to make sure they don't try to get
away
lastly Aizawa has his goggles that were
actually given to him by his friend
Alberto Sheila Kuehl Oh Alberto passed
away sadly but when he was alive he was
always pushing Aizawa who naturally lack
confidence to believe in himself
Alberto gave him goggles when they ran
into an enemy who could use smoke to
make Aizawa square cancel and quark
impossible to use the goggles were
ordinary goggles rather than Kanye
West's goggles and they kept the smoke
from bothering Aizawa Aizawa kept the
goggles as part of this hero outfit but
later modified them because the glass of
the goggles could easily break and hurt
his eyes
Aizawa needed and
protective layer that's how we got the
modern kanye west design which has the
added benefit of hiding aizawa's true
target
so opponents can't predict who he's
going to use his court gone next
for fact number seven let's look at
Aizawa statistics according to the
official my hero academia data books in
the first one he scored an average three
out of five or c in power a solid four
out of five or B in speed and
exceptional six out of five or s in
technique is solid four out of five or B
in intelligence and they not so
impressive three out of five or see in
cooperativeness so Aizawa strengths
appear to be a speed his technique in
his intelligence while he's naturally
not that strong or cooperative and that
makes sense since he can be a
standoffish introvert as we've seen the
exceptional technique score reflects how
hard Isaiah worked to overcome his own
natural shortcomings so we got to
respect him for that most people who got
aizawa's quark probably would have left
the fighting to other pro heroes while
they simply assisted them without
entering the fray but Aizawa made it a
point to become a great fighter in his
own right without the help of an Opie
fighting quirk in the second data book
Aizawa still had a C in power but his
speed was upgraded to a B+ his technique
to an S Plus and his intelligence to an
A plus his customized category was dry
eyes and you can bet he got a perfect 6
out of 6 or s in that I really enjoy
these data books and I like seeing
characters progress from one to the next
and I appreciate the fact that the pro
heroes can grow as well as the students
sometimes we assume that adults are
stuck in their ways and shown and but
know they can surpass their limits too
and that makes the series much more
interesting for fact number eight let's
take a closer look at aizawa's Japanese
voice actor the 48 year old Junichi
Suwabe genichi is also a singer and won
the best singing award at the say u
awards and say you just means voice
actor if you were wondering you also won
the Best Supporting voice actor at the
7th save Awards this talented rock star
also plays another very important mentor
Yami from black clover he also played
green in Full Metal Alchemist and Archer
and fate/stay night among many many
other notable roles what with being a
rock star
in the voice of so many cool characters
you can't deny that Junichi Suwabe is a
legend at this point and definitely a
great choice for the very cool Aizawa
and it doesn't even need to be said but
you know that people as cool as Junichi
in Aizawa always smash that like button
no question next for fact number nine
let's turn to the English voice actors
for Aizawa that's right actors let me
explain for season one Alex Oregon was
the voice actor for Aizawa he also
appeared in anime like Psychopaths and
the boy and the beast as of 2020
according to TV tropes org alex is
focusing on theater production and
directing so he's not currently voice
acting for the following seasons Aizawa
was dug by christopher la cam who also
appeared in anime like black clover and
attack on titan and finally we have
arrived to the lightning round where in
lieu of fact number 10 I list as many
facts as I can in a relatively short
period of time three to one less Jam
aizawa's birthday's on November 8th
making him a Scorpio according to google
Scorpios are defined by their shyness
they also set goals for themselves and
work hard to accomplish them this works
well because I saw was a shy kid
compared to most and as we saw he worked
hard in order to become a great fighter
without an overpowered quark he's
originally 30 years old when the series
starts and he's currently 31 and as
someone in my mid-20s I always
appreciate seeing characters older than
me who inspire me just as they inspire
the main characters as always 183
centimeters tall or six feet that's
pretty tall compared to the average
Japanese height which according to
Google is around 160 centimeters or 5
foot 2 inches but it's still nowhere
close to all my twin his muscular form
is 220 centimeters tall or 7 foot 2
inches
I saw his blood type is B and his eye
color when using his quirk is different
in the anime and manga his usually black
eyes turned red in the anime and yellow
in the manga and that is it for this one
another MHA fact series video down
making for a total of 11 which is pretty
crazy this series has gone on for quite
a while and if you want to keep it going
be sure to smash that like button and
leave suggestions for who you want me to
cover next in the comment
remember if we can't hit 4,000 likes
4,000 1000 times 4 I'll get started on
the next one
ASAP if you haven't be sure
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell or you will miss
future mh8 videos on this channel and
after you've turned that like button
blue and share this video with your
cultured friends who like my hero
academia you can check out my MH a fact
series playlist as you impatiently wait
for the next installment link in the
description
lastly the YouTube ad rates have dropped
big-time so the support we're getting
from our anime out for patrons is very
appreciated a very special thank you
goes for patrons over on patreon WAP has
survived these YouTube issues and who
helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost I want to
thank our the one tier patrons the ones
who sat atop all clans Steven and Radha
a Lola not and dull world Steelers
acquire respect but a heffa Jonathan
King Brandon of Isles
Papa Smurf the School Bus King riser
Emperor otaku Ricardo Martinez Thomas
Jones kin mono Michael hi and Jayden the
vector controller and our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings
algae's Anatole Kazansky angel Cruz
cricket XV Joel Stanton Barry Gucci
Alicia actor Jessica Kayla Fantine okami
and water body parts Saudi art Woolworth
ooh and a aura Kraken or elles and
deadly Saint thank you all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon
complex animal or and becoming a patron
today for as little as $1 if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here and you'll even get access to
our private patrons only Dischord where
we talk about anime life and of course
dank memes so check out
patreon.com/scishow
you can also now join the YouTube
channel and support more content that
way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits thanks again and
until next time see uh space cowboys
[Music]